I have something very exciting for you
today I've been telling you for months
that we are we have been in the process
of developing a critical thinking class
or a critical thinking miniseries which
will be composed of somewhere between 12
and 15 episodes pieces parts and it will
include such topics as understanding the
difference between good and bad
arguments epistemology critical thinking
logical fallacies etc etc etc we have
also since April of 2017 been raising
funds using a platform called patreon
our particular page is at patreon.com
slash david pakman show and what we have
on patreon currently as a target is
2,100 patrons and what I've been
promising to you is that when we reach
2,100 patrons we will record edit and
upload the multi-part critical thinking
miniseries we will first upload it and
distribute it and make it available to
the patrons but eventually for full
distribution because I think that the
content is so important critical
thinking skills are so lacking in the
United States I have for you today an
almost completely finished version of
one clip now remember I said it would be
12 to 15 parts I've got one example of
what the series will be like this is
from the middle-right this is from the
meat of the miniseries the topics are
going to range as I said this particular
clip I'm going to play for you today is
our part on validity and soundness of
arguments the audio from it is one part
but the animation and the video
component which producer Noah Ferguson
has been working on is excellent and
it's really some of the best stuff that
I believe we will have put out when we
finally do so if you're just listening
today find this clip online and check
out the great visual components this is
what we're shooting for 2100 patrons for
right this is one part of the eventual
mini-series on critical thinking and
logical fallacies let's take a look
let's take a listen we hear the words
valid and validity used all the time but
I want to talk about what validity means
in a technical sense with regard
something we've already discussed
deductive arguments as a reminder a
deductive argument is an argument where
the premises logically guaranteed the
conclusion for example if a is B and B
is C a must be C there is no alternative
the concept of validity is a tool for
evaluating the internal logic of a
deductive argument to say that an
argument is valid is not the same as
saying that the argument is good or
sound for example imagine the premise
that all dogs can fly and the second
premise that Fido is a dog the
conclusion would be that Fido can fly
although it might seem counterintuitive
this is a valid argument an argument is
valid if the truth of the premises would
guarantee the truth of the conclusion if
it is true that all dogs can fly then it
must be true that Fido the dog can fly
but let's put this argument under more
scrutiny this is a valid argument but it
is not a sound argument soundness is an
evaluation of both whether an argument
is valid and whether its premises are
true a sound argument must be both valid
and have true premises not all dogs can
fly so one of the premises is false and
our argument is not sound so validity
and soundness are properties of an
argument and truth is a property of a
statement here's an argument that is
sound because it is both valid and has
true premises all US senators are
politicians Ted Cruz is a US senator the
conclusion is that Ted Cruz is a
politician it's a horrible reality but
it is a reality and it is a sound
argument here's an argument where the
premises are true but the argument is
invalid so the argument is not sound
Paris is a city Germany is a country
conclusion Paris is the capital of
Germany it's not sound because that
conclusion is not guaranteed by the
truth of the premises or what about this
one Marco Rubio is a Republican which is
true Hillary Clinton is a Democrat which
is true
and the conclusion is that Jill Stein is
a member of the Green Party in this
particular case both of the premises are
true and the conclusion happens to be
true but the two premises don't
logically guarantee that conclusion so
the argument is invalid and therefore it
is not sound we should only accept
conclusions of arguments that are both
valid and sound Wow yeah impressive
right I mean this is 12 to 15 parts
talking through these exact types of
critical thinking questions that would
be so great if they were being taught in
school they're just not so I guess we'll
have to teach them to people and I'm
like a smart person but I'm also
learning a lot here absolutely so this
is a donor goal when we get to 2,100
donors as they are called on patreon
patrons or portray on I like saying
petraea as I heard it once online and
it's so funny you go to portray on duck
na komm slash david pakman show
contribute a doll or contribute $10
whatever when we get to 2,100 patrons I
will have more news about the critical
thinking miniseries let's take a break
we will be back after this